for everything you have going on to do
this
I love her and Rob did you take care of
so many people
you do no it's amazing
I just can't believe that you're
basically like somewhat of a co-parent
it's a dream I mean you guys having fun
up there
you're like more than an aunt
probably more than an amp right less
than a just a third parent it's amazing
and the third the third wheel they're
not the Third Wheel they're like the
wheel that makes the car move
dream is one of my babies too just like
all the rest of them and I absolutely
love being a mom to people let's do the
cake and then you can eat we're gonna do
the cake first I love mothering people I
don't know if they like that or not
[Music]
but it's so in my blood just to be a mom
I wouldn't have it any other way